hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be discussing
Kourtney Kardashian's extreme diet
restrictions and the potential
trickle-down effect for her kids and you
can pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always please
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and guys if
you're not already subscribed don't
forget to hit that subscribe button ring
that Bell and follow me on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen alright
before we get into the video I want to
play another round of Abby's daily
hunger crushing combo so I've got some
yogurt in my Bowl here I'm craving just
like a really simple cereal I just need
that crunch Factor so I've got some kind
of high fiber cereal here going on
into my yogurt
I've got some banana this gives us our
carbs for some great energy in the
morning
a handful of blueberries
a little spoonful of jam
because I love that especially with the
plain yogurt and I'm gonna bust out my
belt bar granola bar this is the
chocolate peanut butter flavor hello
it's gonna rock this recipe so you guys
know that I love these because they
taste like chocolate because they're
made with actual real chocolate and this
one has 15 grams of protein per bar so
I'm just gonna chop this up get little
bits of that granola peanut butter
chocolate flavor all throughout our
little breakfast bowl here
I'm going to top it off with a little
handful of salted nuts just to complete
the look
this is delicious I can't wait to dig in
check that out
so if you want to try build bar for
yourself check out the link in my
description and use my promo code Abby
sharp15 to get 15 off of your order
now Courtney has certainly made a name
for herself as the wellness Queen of the
Kardashian Clan so much so that she's
even launched her own Wellness brand
push and most recently started her own
line of multivitamins called Lemmy now
while I'm all for living your best
healthiest life whatever that might look
like for you I do think that this can
potentially be taken too far especially
when those restrictions are enforced
onto kids you guys know we need to talk
about this so let's get a lay of the
land to understand some of Courtney's
alleged diet rules I don't think I can
eat it anymore why
because it has cheese I'm doing
non-dairy and it has gluten in the bread
but you were fine eating this for years
and years and years no
this used to be your favorite sandwich
I've known Courtney for a very long time
and all of a sudden she thinks she's
allergic to everything I don't even
think she knows what gluten is I I don't
do you no does anybody but I don't think
it's fair to tell everyone you're
allergic to all these things and then go
have a glass of milk or eat a big ice
cream and be like oh it's a cheat day
you can't cheat on allergy since Scott
is being ridiculous I won't call my diet
restrictions and Allergy since that
seems to be offending Scott I'll just
say that it's like a healthy lifestyle
so much to say about this honestly big
trigger warning right here I'm going to
be talking about my own past Ed but this
is kind of how my eating disorder
orthorexia started in the first place
basically with me thinking I was
allergic to a bunch of foods that I was
not and then removing them from my diet
in the name of health and the funny
thing about eliminating foods like Dairy
due to a mild intolerance is you can
actually make yourself more intolerant
in short when you stop eating dairy for
example you stop producing the lactase
enzyme so even a lick of ice cream on
your cheat day can cause major digital
test of distress just reinforcing the
fear of that food so I definitely agree
with Scott that a willingness to cheat
on an alleged allergy or intolerance is
a pretty good indicator that this is
just a food or caloric restriction under
the guise of some kind of glamorized
Lifestyle Courtney's rationale for this
diet has also flip-flopped a lot in the
media over the years so she's been
quoted as saying that she always felt
fine eating gluten and dairy but that
cutting them out was just kind of like a
personal choice and that she's also
being quoted suggesting that she's
tested positive for gluten and dairy
sensitivities via muscle testing spoiler
alert guys muscle testing is not a legit
allergy test I mean basically this test
has you hold a suspected allergen in
your hand and then decide if you're
allergic or not just by applying
pressure to an extended arm and seeing
if you can hold it up it is the
definition of a non-scientific invalid
test
that sounds fake but okay so yeah I'm
going with the healthy lifestyle
rationale on this one for her and
speaking of this rationale perpetuating
the idea that removing gluten and dairy
is automatically a healthier lifestyle
is problematic as especially when we're
pushing unnecessary restrictions onto
kids removing a nutritious food or food
group from a diet can only be healthier
if eating those Foods literally is
making you sick we need to remember that
gluten-free foods tend to be lower in
Iron fiber B vitamins magnesium and
selenium compared to their gluten-filled
counterparts not to mention a lot of
dairy-free milks are lower in protein
calcium and vitamin D of course these
Alternatives may be healthier depending
on your goals but they also might not be
especially in childhood when nutrient
needs are very high and the risk of
picky eating is even higher in fact we
even have research showing that children
with celiac disease following a
gluten-free diet are 20 to 40 percent
more likely to experience calorie and
protein imbalance as well as fiber
mineral and vitamin deficiencies it's
also worth pointing out that gluten-free
products are up to 160 percent more
expensive than their gluten containing
counterparts and while the extra cost
may be no skin off corny's back hopping
on a restrictive diet unnecessarily can
often be used as a display of elitism
and financial privilege but let's move
on to another diet restriction in
Courtney's household that she probably
cannot justify as an intolerance or
allergy sugar-free I can't eat this but
how exciting is it to smell it
Courtney has this vision of no sugar or
no disgusting chemicals and Candy a
completely sugar-free gluten-free hearty
free fun free zone because Courtney has
decided that it just doesn't make sense
and it really wasn't the theme of what
North and Penelope wanted for their
birthday there's just better solutions
to things instead of your dated candy
that's like literally food coloring that
gives people diseases so I totally
respect making an effort to enjoy high
sugar foods in moderation however
villainizing sugar to the extent that
you're sniffing donuts for Thrills and
banning any candy at a Candy Land themed
party is arguably not best practice
first of all completely restricting
sugar in your household does nothing but
set children up to have a turbulent
relationship with sugar containing foods
and this is because when we make sugar
forbidden or call it bad it only makes
children and let's be real us adults too
want it that much more and once children
are outside the controlled household
environment and have exposure to these
Foods they're just a lot more likely to
overeat them but I need candy we can
only run a tight sugar-free ship for so
long until our kids become young adults
who have to make their own decisions
about what to eat and what do you think
a child who's never been allowed candy
is going to do when they get their first
job they're going to blow their 15 an
hour wages on candy and a ton of it kids
also tend to really internalize messages
that they hear about food and bodies if
they eat a food that mommy calls bad or
calls herself bad for eating then they
start to feel shame and guilt for being
bad too so what are we to do as parents
of course we don't want our kids to just
eat candy when they're so little and
young but we also don't want them to
become adults who are obsessed with
eating candy I discuss my tips in my
video on the division of responsibility
right here but basically I have two main
tricks for this number one try serving a
single child size portion of something
sweet like the dessert with the meal it
doesn't have to be earned it's not a
bribe for eating broccoli so they can
eat it whenever they want during that
meal and then two occasionally offer
unlimited sweets at snack time so this
might be like a plate of mini chocolate
bars after Halloween or mini cookies at
Christmas or letting them choose
whatever sweets they like at a birthday
party or event this is a long game folks
like parenting in general is a long game
but this is the most reliable way to
teach kids that candy is really no
different than broccoli or rice it's not
deserving of being put on a pedestal or
Obsession and we can be relaxed about it
because we know that it's not going away
for good and here's the ironic thing
about Courtney's unique combination of
restrictions we know that on average
most gluten-free products actually
contain more sugar saturated fat and
salt than their gluten containing
counterparts so for example this
gluten-free pancake mix contains six
grams of sugar per serving compared to
the regular pancake mix which only
contains one gram of sugar per serving
so putting these dietary restrictions in
place for her kids unnecessarily might
actually end up backfiring for Courtney
lastly I want to quickly comment on
Courtney's food dye shade my assumption
being that she's worried about the
alleged hyperactivity that it causes in
children so what we know from a review
of the literature is that certain food
dyes can increase hyperactivity in
children but other research suggests
that this effect is largely genetically
determined in other words not all kids
will react the same way and like with
all food additives and Foods some kids
may be sensitive While others are not
but do food dyes give people diseases as
Courtney claims well basically all the
research showing a link between food
dyes and cancer has been done on rats
red 3 is definitely most controversial
food dye but it's basically being
completely replaced in our food system
with red dye 40. and ultimately even if
you were exposed the dose makes the
poison I don't know about you guys but I
can't remember the last time my kids ate
an entire container of maraschino
cherries listen I'm a parent too I
totally understand and respect wanting
to limit our kids exposure to certain
ingredients when we can and honestly to
have our kids eat mostly nutritious
foods but a birthday party isn't an
everyday occurrence and letting your
kids have a lollipop once in a while is
likely to be more beneficial in the long
run than absolute abstinence because it
may reduce the long-term drive to over
consume but now we know what Courtney's
kids are not eating so what do they
allegedly eat in a day well according to
an online Source breakfast is typically
gluten-free waffles with scrambled eggs
lunch will usually be gluten-free
tortillas with turkey meat and a side of
carrots celery and hummus and dinner is
some kind of steamed veg gluten-free
pizza and some lean protein like fish
this sounds incredible like an amazing
range of options and it actually sounds
kind of similar to my kids favorite
meals as well however with their
specific dietary restrictions we would
definitely want to prioritize more
calcium-rich foods from things like
leafy greens beans calcium set tofu nuts
seeds and fortified beverages like
orange juice and plant-based milk I'm
also kind of surprise not to see fruit
on the menu like I really hope she's not
limiting natural sugars too since kids
need a lot of carbs in their day but I
actually think that adding in some more
fruit would be a great source of added
fiber to make up for some of the lower
fiber grains in a gluten-free diet if
this diet is working for the kids and
they are thriving right now we love to
see it but I'm always mindful of the
long-term game when it comes to helping
kids Foster a healthy relationship with
food so I want to share with you some of
the main reasons why I worry about some
of these unnecessary restrictions for
Courtney's kids number one kids with
dietary restrictions are at risk of
under nutrition considering the high
prevalence of fussy eating in children
which research suggests is around 20 to
60 percent it can be that much more
challenging to try to close the
nutritional gaps in an unnecessarily
restricted diet in fact most research
suggests that picky eaters have lower
nutrient adequacy even when on a
non-restricted diet but the trajectory
of fussy eating can be altered by
following the division of responsibility
and encouraging a non-binary
non-restrictive approach to eating
alternatively being overrestrictive with
food dichotomizing food as good or bad
or using it as punishment or rewards is
also associated with a greater risk of
picky eating so food restriction might
actually exacerbate picky eating while
also increasing the risk of under
nutrition number two restricted children
are also more likely to overeat my
social media feed was recently set
Ablaze when Courtney revealed that she
had banned her son Mason from eating
McDonald's for a whole year and after
pleading with his mom to please let him
have some Mickey D's french fries corny
responded with a hard no savage so we
have seen time and time again both in
the research and of course anecdotally
that restrictive feeding practices like
this may promote overeating in children
in fact one study found that children
who were exposed to a high level of
restriction at age five were more likely
to overeat at age seven and nine and as
I mentioned earlier when children feel
deprived of certain foods they're more
likely to overeat hoard or binge on the
Forbidden Foods in secret number three
restricted children are more likely to
become dieters one study found that
children of dieting mothers are more
likely to diet at a younger age compared
to Children whose mother never dieted
not to mention exposure to dieting at a
young age only increases the likelihood
of dieting and adulthood which can open
up a big can of worms including risky
dieting behaviors more weight cycling
episodes and ultimately higher body
weight number four restricted kids feel
a greater sense of Shame and guilt
around food in a recent interview with
the Wall Street Journal Courtney praised
her son Mason for being a smart kid for
saying a person was bad because they let
me have Cheetos what the the actual
folks if you're teaching your child that
a person is bad for allowing you to eat
a cheese puff you are teaching your
child disordered eating patterns and
Prejudice and we have researched to show
that restrictive feeding increases the
risk of negative self-evaluation where
kids feel guilt shame or negative
self-talk when they eat the alleged bad
foods and finally number five restricted
kids can feel socially isolated and left
out and how are the kids handling it
they like hate me we went we had Rob's
birthday party on Saturday night I saw
and he had this huge cake and I brought
them these gluten-free dairy-free
chocolate chip cookies I was but I
warned them in advance they were fine
but Mason loves cake and he was
not happy oh my god listen some dietary
restrictions are for the safety and
well-being of the child and when they're
old enough they can easily understand
that bringing an allergy free
alternative to a party where there's an
offending food that maybe you're
allergic to is an act of self-care and
love but if there is no legitimate
reason for the Restriction kids will
feel resentful and distrustful and again
when they're no longer under your watch
they will likely Rebel and overeat as a
fellow mom I never want to make a mom
feel like she's doing harm I know that
we are all just doing our absolute best
trying to keep our kids healthy and
happy with the tools that we have access
to so this is really not so much a
critique of Courtney herself seeing as
this experience is just so common
amongst so many Health concerned parents
I'm concerned about my kids health too I
really really am but when you know
better you can do better and those of us
with complicated histories with food
want to do better we all want to stop
that generational diet culture cycle for
good so I hope this video was
informative for your own Journeys and
let's stay empathetic to Courtney in her
own Parenthood and food Journey herself
and that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up leave me a comment
below with what you'd like to see me
talk about next subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]